what's going on guys this is rob and we
need to make this a regular series so
the marvel cinematic universe needs
galactus it's not one of those the mcu
wants a galactus or the mcu should have
galactus the mcu needs galactus and
here's the reason why so let's talk
about his origin for a second right
galactus origin is actually really
really intriguing and it actually comes
in two parts so in the old thor stories
from back in the day the explanation
that we got in terms of galactus origin
is that he was just a space explorer and
his universe was coming to an end and he
didn't know why and he was the last
surviving thing in his universe and so
the sentience of that universe merged
with him and then he was reborn into the
new universe as galactus and that's it
that's all we really got now years later
marvel gave us a story called adventures
of the x-men really a comic line called
adventures of the x-men but what this
did is it actually said the death of
gallon's universe was just part of a
much bigger picture that gallon didn't
know about that the reality of what was
going on is that the sixth iteration of
the multiverse was basically dying that
the dweller in darkness had fractured
the emcron crystal and in doing so the
imcron crystal basically became a black
hole sucking in the multiverse and that
what the dweller in darkness wanted to
do was to absorb the energy of the
multiverse and then make himself god
ultimately he was defeated but by the
time he was defeated the end of the
multiverse could not be stopped and so
when gallons universe died it was
actually the multiverse dying and that's
why when galin was reborn as galactus
there was actually a version of galactus
in every single universe across the
multiverse now more recently in the
doctor strange defenders story i guess
galactus origin is kind of being
rewritten i don't really know we don't
know if it's going to stick or not but
as far as the actual origin that's tried
and true that's the one that you get but
having him in the mcu would be hugely
intriguing because let's do what we said
we would do in these videos back when we
first started doing them and let's focus
on our kind of like i guess would be
tried and true villain in the mcu up to
this point which is thanos right he's
kind of the gold standard right thanos
basically blinked out half the life of
the universe because his world died out
because there were too many people and
not enough resources and he believed
that's what would happen across the
whole universe so he basically just
blinked out half the life in the
universe i mean you guys have all seen
the memes though right like you know why
didn't you just double all the resources
in the universe thanos or why didn't you
do what the council of reeds did which
was take entire worlds that were
basically barren use your infinity
gauntlet and turn them into
life-supporting worlds so you can
literally just grow resources on those
worlds and take them to places where
resources are scarce even then in a
thousand years everything is going to be
right back to where it was before so
literally thanos made no progress
whatsoever but you know the plot
demanded the story so that's the story
we got but thanos is two dimensional
he's basic he's not very interesting
he's done some cool stuff and seeing
some of the things he did was cool but
when you break it down beyond like the
eye candy the glitz and glamour and you
look at thanos as an actual villain in
the mcu he's not interesting not really
in the slightest galactus defies that
standard so here's an important thing to
understand about his character galactus
doesn't like doing what he does galactus
hates the idea of traveling around the
cosmos and consuming life-sustaining
worlds it he despises it right like
literally it's what he said over and
over and over again he views his
existence as a curse and there's a lot
of story lines out there that actually
solidify this the original secret wars
in 1984 when the beyonder first appeared
i don't know if you guys read that story
but quite literally it was a booming
voice from the sky right all the heroes
and all the villains had basically been
taken and they'd all been thrown on two
different ships the villains went on one
ship and the heroes went on the other
and the beyonder was just like all of
you guys basically fight to the death
and whoever wins i will grant your
wildest stream and the response of
galactus was you can cure me of my
hunger which of course the beyonder
batted galactus away like he was nothing
and he's like no you get down there and
you fight
and then i will give you your wish if
you win but it's one of those cool
little moments because galactus
consistently just reiterates the fact
that he hates his existence for him it's
a curse but he's also a necessity now
there's two reasons why galactus is a
necessity the first is the one that was
originally given to us which was he just
is and the second one is an actual
explanation so the first one that was
given to us is an old story called the
the trial of reed richards that reed
richards was basically put on trial by
the various empires of the universe
right the shiar the cree the scroll the
badoon the whole nine yards because he
had saved the life of galactus and in
doing so he had essentially doomed
countless people across countless
civilizations until the end of the
universe to their deaths because
galactus would show up to their world
consume them and pretty much kill all
those people in the process and so
during this trial the cosmic entity
eternity appeared to everybody granting
every single person cosmic awareness
right everybody at that trial granted
them cosmic awareness so they were able
to understand the tapestry right the
kind of cosmic hierarchy and what he
established is galactus has to exist
right he serves a purpose in the
universe that getting mad at galactus
consuming a life-sustaining world is
like being mad at a supernova exploding
and then basically wiping everything out
right like wiping out an entire star
system that's what it's like it's just
the natural order of things but in
reality the answer we got is because it
just is just that way and like that was
it now fast forward to a couple stories
the first one is called earth x and the
second one is shield by jonathan hickman
earth x is actually what the eternals
film is based off of and we talked about
that in previous videos but it's
basically the the eternals film in terms
of the celestials right depositing their
essences right basically banging planets
and like depositing their essence into
that planet and then eventually that
celestial egg will grow to become a full
celestial it'll emerge and destroy the
planet in the process the role galactus
played in the earth x series is that he
would consume worlds that that
celestials could use to deposit their
eggs in in effect he was keeping the
celestial population in check now for
years and years and years this was a
one-off it was isolated it was by itself
it was not the standard in more recent
years with jonathan hickman shield it
became a standard so that's basically
what galactus does now he travels around
the cosmos but here's where galactus
would really benefit in the marvel
cinematic universe and it's probably one
of the most important things galactus
despite him being a guy that consumes
life-sustaining worlds and can create
life and destroy life and is is almost
omnipotent in terms of the power he has
that he's actually as much a supporting
character for other characters and
comics as he is this godly being so
there's a couple really good examples of
this the first one is reed richards
himself along with franklin richards and
the second one is the ultimate so like
black panther adam bashir monica rambo
america chavez carol danvers right those
characters right the ultimate avengers
the multiversal avengers essentially so
looking at like reed and franklin
there's a couple different things to
understand about this the first is that
galactus has been around the block more
than a few times reid richards is the
smartest person in the universe and so
galactus has a lot of respect for reid
that nine times out of ten if anybody
runs up on goliath and tries to talk to
him he'll just ignore him he'll treat
him like they're not there because the
reality here is let's take an average
person on earth right our lives are
anywhere between 80 to 90 years it's
like that for galactus right it's the
blink of an eye fraction of a second
right just just
an infinitely decimal
small amount of time for a guy who's
lived for billions of years and will
live for billions more right so the fact
that like read is even fascinating to
him is is one of those things that's
just kind of crazy and and it really is
a testament to how important reid is in
the grand scheme of marvel comics
franklin is even more interesting
because when franklin richards was
really really young he had the ability
to alter reality and he still does right
he's a universal constant he can alter
reality on a cosmic scale and in fact at
the end of all things when the universe
dies franklin and galactus will actually
merge into a singular being and be
reborn as a new composite being right
but the important thing here is that
there came a point that because franklin
couldn't necessarily control his powers
we'd put mental blocks in place there
came a point during jonathan hickman's
fantastic four where those blocks were
removed by franklin's adult self and
then younger franklin was basically
tapping into his powers there comes a
point in the story where galactus
snatches up reed and was like we need to
go have a conversation and reid's like
okay what's going on and galactus
terrified when he says it he's like your
son's powers have come back franklin has
his powers again he can alter reality on
a cosmic scale again right a 12 year old
kid who can basically make anything
reality it's a terrifying prospect but
it's one of those things where despite
how powerful galactus is putting him
next to someone basically amps up the
significance of that person you kind of
have to build on the idea that galactus
just doesn't really care but if it's one
of those things where like you have reid
richards right john krasinski's read uh
reed richards in the the marvel
cinematic universe he's a guy who does
his thing right he's just kind of like a
scientist you know and you may look at
him as like a poor man's tony stark or
something like that galactus shows up
and it's like read we have to talk and
it's like damn
it's like the president of the united
states busting into your classroom
addressing you by your first name and
saying you and i need to have a comment
have a conversation right people are
just gonna be like damn
who is that guy right that's how people
are going to react
the other part of this is al ewing's
ultimates right the ultimate avengers
were a really really really cool team
the first story arc they got was
actually fixing galactus that when they
analyzed and they realized that he was
basically an incomplete evolution that
he was supposed to continue on but for
whatever reason he didn't so they
basically finished his evolution for him
and turned him into the lifebringer but
what you're talking about here black
panther like right adam beshear adam
berscher is probably smarter than black
panther but like these guys are
ridiculously powerful and incredibly
capable and they were able to fix a
cosmic entity that's a big thing so
having galactus in the mcu would
certainly amplify characters in a way
that simply can't be done because to be
honest with you guys there's only so
many stories that you can tell where
like galactus shows up on earth and then
like wants to consume it the fantastic
four and the earth superheroes fight him
off the silver surfer stays behind
because he betrayed galactus and now
he's trapped here you know it's just one
of those you can only tell that story so
many times before people are just kind
of like i mean look i'm tired of seeing
galactus you know fight these guys
instead what galactus needs to be in the
marvel cinematic universe and this is
the most important thing that i think
really needs to be reiterated here
galactus needs to be a guy who shows up
for a film arc right he shows up right
it's basically the the marvel marvel
cinematic universe version of the uh the
original galactus trilogy and marvel
comics right the old stan lee jack kirby
story where galaches shows up to earth
with the intention of consuming it the
silver surfer warns a fantastic four
ahead of time the fantastic four work
with silver surfer his heart changes and
then he helps them fight off galactus
and then galactus traps him on earth as
punishment for his for his betrayal
right you do that yeah he doesn't have
to be exactly like that but like you do
the galactus trilogy following that
galactus only ever appears every once in
a while and when he shows up it's a big
thing because what you don't want to do
is overuse him you don't want to have
one of these things where it's like man
the latches are showing up all the time
that's crazy that's what marvel did with
the watcher and marvel comics they did
that with the watcher every time the
watchers showed up it was a big deal and
then after a while it's just like okay
so he's just kind of here hanging out
watching stuff maybe it's a big deal
maybe it's not right because he's in the
peanuts gallery that's all it was right
it didn't matter that the watcher was
there anymore and so you don't want to
abuse the nature of galactus in the mcu
you want to have it as one of these
things where he's always kind of this
lingering threat that's out there but
after the threat is dealt with here on
earth and you basically walk away from
the movie with this idea of okay so
galactus isn't really going to be a
credible threat to earth anymore now it
becomes one of those things where he
bolsters characters right they need the
help of galactus there's some massive
threat out there they need the aid of
galactus more so than that you can
actually amplify the power of villains
by having them defeat galactus now again
you can't abuse this right you can't
have like any swinging with the infinity
gauntlet just like yeah man i'd be
galactus it was amazing you know it's
like well so did like 15 other people
right who cares it can't be one of those
things right galactus has to be handled
very very delicately he has to be
handled in a way to where you're able to
produce him to the audience as just this
clear and present danger by some
mystical means probably the use of the
ultimate nullifier they're able to
defeat galactus and basically run him
off and then he's always kind of this
lingering threat out there right like a
shark that's just off the coast and if
you swim out just 10 more feet you're
gonna get eaten right just that kind of
thing right a guy who's just sort of out
there but he can help as much as he can
hurt but the presence of his arrival
right seeing him show up means it's a
big deal something huge is about to
happen right like that's what galactus
has to represent otherwise he becomes
exactly what he is right now in all the
comics a guy who's just kind of a
punching bag so with that being said
guys let me know what you think about
having galactus in the marvel cinematic
universe do you want to see it are you
excited about the idea of it let me know
how you guys feel thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace